[Music]
from outside it looks like a truck but
inside it's like a spaceship this is the
heart of this huge media operation
sending video images of the summit TVs
TVs all around the world hi Noemi hi can
you tell us what's going on here uh
actually here is where we received the
images from all our cameras and we give
them to the media in real time for their
new stories it's like a football match
yes we need many cameras to follow the
action ah is that short speaking yes but
as you can see the Estonian leader has
just arrived in the Italian Prime
Minister is on her way
so the next time you see your leader is
in Brussels you'll know where the images
came from